COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we take a look at the read/write
performance of our storage
buckets.
Will everything fit in
the overhead compartments?
Stay tuned to find out.
Over the last few
weeks, we've had
a lot of interest from
web developers regarding
the performance of Google
Cloud Storage, which
is listed as a unified object
storage solution in the Cloud.
Or in simpler
terms, it's a place
in the cloud to serve files.
We've got some followup articles
on exact questions they ask,
but before we get
to those, I wanted
to establish a
baseline of performance
for reading and writing to GCS.
For most web developers,
read performance from GCS
is kind of a big deal.
I mean, any time you
use it for static data,
like webs or game files, you
want that as fast as possible.
To test this, we placed an
asset in a region bucket
in US Central, and
then fetched that asset
from a bunch of machines
located around the world.
Now, because this
bucket is regional,
the graph shows that the
farther away the request,
the higher the latency due
to-- you know-- physics.
Turning on caching or using
a multi-regional bucket
should easily fix
this, but we'll
talk about that in
a different video.
Just stay tuned.
Of course, on the other side of
the coin is write performance.
If you've got a lot of users
uploading images from their 3G
devices straight into GCS, then
write performance is probably
a big deal for you.
To test this, let's just
upload the same file
under different names
to the US Central
1 bucket from various
places in the world.
Now, again, the graph
shows that the farther away
uploads take a
little longer time,
but it's within expectations
given the size of the file.
Now, direct read/write
performance is easy to test,
but in honesty, there's
lots of variables
here that influence
performance, which
make it a pain to write
proper benchmarking for.
Thankfully, you don't have
to write all of those tests
yourself.
The gsutil perfdiag command
runs a suite of diagnostic tests
for a given cloud
storage bucket,
giving information on
latency and throughput
tests for read, write, delete,
download, metadata, and upload
operations.
So if you're ever
in doubt about how
your GCS bucket is performing,
perfdiag is a great first step.
And if you're in doubt about the
rest of your Cloud performance,
check out the associated
article for this video linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas
content because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]